If people could understand that this is akin to the scariest thing you've ever done,...
...then they'll start to understand why we're so addicted to it.
When I put the goggles on, first thing I'm doing is try to calm down.
It totally puts you inside the drone.
You just forget who you are.
I'm Conrad Miller, also known as Furadi, and I'm a drone racer.
I started in September 2014 and that was like the ground floor.
Of all the activities I've partaken in,...
...motorcycles and flying drones are on the same level in terms of intensity.
It's cool when you have a hobby and you can do it and you love it.
But when you can share it with your kids,...
...I mean, that's just like what it's all about, I think.